[Applause]
this is a momentous occasion
actually because I've decided to take
this
opportunity as I stand before so many
patriots and lovers of freedom to
announce my candidacy for the presidency
of the United
States
now you might think this is a joke and
of course it is I have no political
experience I've never held elected
office never even run for office I have
no Organization no staff and no money I
am not now and have never been a member
of the Washington establishment in other
words I'm just the man for the
job now there's a serious point that I'm
making here the point is that the
problem is not Barack Obama the problem
is not the
Democrats Barack Obama and the Democrats
are just symptoms of the problem the
problem is an entrenched Washington
establishment that keeps failing again
and again and yet it keeps on applying
the same failed solutions to
problems presidents come and presidents
go but this establishment is forever and
no matter how many times its remedies
fail it keeps on applying them without
an ounce of
self-reflection now what we need is a
massive house cleaning what we need is a
genuine Outsider elected with a mandate
to do this house cleaning to really open
up the windows in the state department
and let in the sunlight and clear out
all these failed ideas that are doing
nothing less than leading this nation
into
disaster now the entrenched
establishment is operating of course in
all areas but I'm going to concentrate
on foreign policy because if we don't
stop making some of the major foreign
policy mistakes that we are making then
we won't have to worry about domestic
policy before too
long now Chief among these is the
millions that we are showering upon the
Palestinians and the so-called peace
process Obama of course blames Israel
for failing to make peace and blames the
failure of peace talks on the so-called
settlements in the West Bank and gives
the impression that he believes or wants
us to believe that if this settlement
construct is stopped then peace will
ensue and everything will be okay now
there's just one word to show that that
is obviously howlingly false and that
one word is
Gaza we heard this song before in 2005
we were told that the occupation was the
problem and if Israel withdrew from Gaza
the gazans would pursue peace Mortimer
Zuckerman spent $14 million to buy the
green houses that the Israelis had
constructed in Gaza in order to give
them to the Palestinians so they would
have gainful employ the Palestinians
gratefully received the green houses and
immediately gutted them and converted
them into weapon smuggling tunnels
between Sinai and Gaza to get weapons to
Hamas now Obama and John KY want us to
withdraw want Israel to withdraw from
Judea and Samaria that is the West Bank
and they say the same things that we
heard about Gaza this will bring peace
this time this withdrawal from this
occupation this is the one that's going
to do it and everything is going to take
everything will in that will happen
after that will be the result of the
good benefits that come from this
occupation in other words it will take
the wind out of the Jihadi sales
altogether
now we saw that this didn't work and yet
keep keep trying it again why would the
establishment of a Palestinian State now
after the Muslims rejected it in 1948
rejected it in 2,000 rejected it many
other times why is it going to bring
peace now how could it when the goal of
Israel's total Destruction and hamama
which Hamas has repeatedly and recently
reiterated Still Remains why would
another Israeli withdrawal accomplish
what the others never have and of course
Israel is not the only victim of our
fantasy based policymaking another one
is us the American taxpayer another
false assumption that is the basis of
policy after policy is that poverty
causes terrorism late in 2013 the US and
turkey announced what they call the
global fund for Community engagement and
resilience and John kery said that this
will provide more economic opportunities
for marginalized youth at risk of
recruitment into Jihad
groups now look we just just saw on the
news this morning another beheading of
the US hostage Peter cig Abdul Rahman
cig whose conversion to Islam did not
save him because he was still considered
as a military veteran to be an American
Crusader the people who beheaded him the
people who were standing there in that
video and issuing warnings to the United
States and the Free World they were
considering themselves to be the
Warriors of
Allah they were considering that they
were at the Vanguard of of a global
Revolution that will bring the law of
God to the world and defeat the enemy
Infidel powers do you really think that
if we gave them an opportunity to say
welcome to McDonald's may I take your
order please that they would give it all
up that they would turn away from what
they think is a glorious struggle in
which they are the soldiers of
God for a job at Walmart it's not going
to happen
this is just going to be more hundreds
of millions of dollars down the drain
not only that but study after study has
shown that terrorists are actually
better educated and wealthier than their
peers just yesterday the news came that
another doctor from the UK fled the
country and has joined the Taliban he's
a doctor he was well off even with the
socialized Health Care system in Britain
but nonetheless he went to Jihad
beyond the waste of money our foreign
policy is characterized these days by an
appalling incoherence take Obama on
Syria the president of course has long
wanted to take out Bashar Assad but he's
been styed by the fact that the only
significant opposition to the Assad
regime are of course Islamic jihadis the
so-called vetted moderates some of the
vetted moderates last year ransacked
churches and drove Christians out of
their homes in three in three Syrian
towns but now Obama is actually pursuing
the strategy of removing Assad because
he thinks that Assad is causing the
Jihadi recruitment so if we take out
Assad then the Islamic State will melt
away we won't even have to fight it the
raison Detra for the terrorists will be
gone now he actually thinks this despite
the fact that the Islamic state has made
it clear that they don't intend to stop
with toppling Assad but they want to
control not only all of Syria but all of
Iraq as well as Kuwait Lebanon Israel
and Jordan and continue on after that
and so the main problem with this idea
is this if he removes Assad he creates a
power vacuum what is the force that is
the only one in position to take
advantage of that power vacuum the
Islamic
State and so what he's saying is in
order to defeat the Islamic State we
have to give the Islamic State what it
wants and let it
win this is
insane and this is the policy of the
United States
government now this is all part of the
idea that if we bring democracy to the
Middle East then peace will once again
ensue and so the United States decided
to go onto to pursue a policy of
toppling the dictators that we had
previously supported in the Middle East
Saddam Hussein of course was first to go
and then Ben Ali in Tunisia Mubarak in
Egypt Gaddafi in Libya of course he was
never a friend of the United States but
the idea was the same
that if these people were gone and the
people in those countries had
self-determination then they would
establish western style secular
republics and once again there would be
peace instead of course there's been
chaos the people that Barack Obama
turned out to be supporting in Egypt and
Libya were Muslim Brotherhood they are
in Syria as well they did not want to
establish western style secular
republics but Sharia regimes they did do
so in Egypt for every year and they so
alienated their own people that 30
million took to the streets and toppled
them at that point and yet this policy
is still in place and we are still
pursuing it so when I get to the Oval
Office on January 20th 2017 and I
promise never to put up my feet on the
desk I will begin to sweep away all this
and Implement new policies first of all
no more Aid no more us Aid not a penny
to countries that engage Sharia
[Applause]
oppression just recently a Muslim mob
murdered a Christian couple accused of
blasphemy in
Pakistan and a Pakistani Christian
leader called on Obama to make USA to
Pakistan contingent upon the repeal of
Pakistan's blasphemy laws by which so
many innocent people have been
victimized brutalized
murdered of course Obama ignored it but
he should not have ignored it he should
have implemented it immediately and gone
farther than that there should be no
more aid to any country or group that
allows for or Advocates the Sharia
oppression of women and non-muslims and
that curtails the freedom of speech in
accord with Islam's prohibition on
criticism of Islam and
as as for the Palestinians they should
get nothing at all nothing until they
stop the genocidal incitement on pal
Palestinian TV teach their children that
Israel must exist that they have a right
to that land that it's their land and
that they must live peacefully with the
Israelis there is appalling genocidal
incitement on Palestinian TV on a
regular basis and it's funded by us this
has to
stop my second executive order will be
to require that government intelligence
and law enforcement agencies speak
honestly and tell the truth about the
threat we face of course we know as her
Builders reminded us yesterday that uh
immediately after a Jihad plot or a
Jihad attack these days Barack Obama
John KY David Cameron in the UK a host
of other leaders rush to the airwaves to
tell us this has nothing to do with
Islam well they have nothing to do with
rationality and Common Sense and the
problem is that this fantasy kills
people
in Fort Hood the superiors of major
nidal Malik Hassan the Fort Hood Jihad
murderer they knew that he was in touch
with anir alaki the Jihad leader in
Yemen they knew that he himself was
preaching Jihad and frightening his
co-workers by preaching it what did they
do did they reprimand him did they fire
him did they demote him did they
prosecute him no they promoted him and
praised him and said US troops can learn
a lot about about him a lot from him
about Islam and you know what they
did but the lesson is still not been
learned and the unreality still
prevails also the Boston Marathon the
FBI disregarded as Michelle Bachman told
us yesterday disregarded intelligence it
received from the Russians about the
bombers the Russians said they were
jihadis right around this time the FBI
on orders from the Obama Administration
was removing all mention of Islam and
Jihad from counterterror training
materials and had fired people who had
trained FBI members including me about
the motives and goals of the jihadis and
so they were being taught that Jihad is
a benign spiritual struggle that ought
to be encouraged the Russians said this
guy so uh timland sarv is a Jihadi and
they probably thought oh how
nice and didn't do a thing and so more
people were killed some people were
maimed for life and it is the result of
this
unreality we also have to and the
exaggerated deference being paid toward
mosques and the fact that the Islamic
Society of Boston which was not only
where the SV Brothers went but where you
saw the Jihad video yesterday that
Michelle had and that video was produced
by a member of the Islamic Society of
Boston afia sadiki went there she's
serving 86 years for plotting to murder
American soldiers in the name of Islam
and Jihad TK Mahana went there he's
doing 17 years for aiding Al-Qaeda uh
and the the mosque itself was founded by
abdur Rahman Alam mudi who is now in
prison for funding Al-Qaeda and yet the
only time the FBI had been there was for
outreach Outreach in other words
reassuring Muslims that the US
government is not
islamophobic people are dying because of
these things I will likewise as
president call upon Muslim groups to
renounce the aspects of sharia that
contradict constitutional freedoms the
US government should call upon advocacy
groups like The Council on American
Islamic relations to renounce in a
sincere and genuine manner any intention
at any point in the future to replace
the US government US Constitution with
Sharia and to implement in American
mosques and Islamic schools in a
transparent and open way that is easily
able to be inspected programs to teach
against this understanding of Islam that
these groups ostensibly reject but have
done nothing to
counter did you know that the United
Arab Emirates is more realistic about
this threat right now than the United
States the UAE is cracking down on
Muslim Brotherhood groups and yesterday
it listed as terrorist organizations a
number of Brotherhood linked groups
around the world including the Council
on American Islamic relations meanwhile
care is meeting with FBI agents and with
Administration officials and is the
go-to group for the mainstream media
about Islamic issues the UAE knows
better coming to abrupt an Abrupt end on
January 20th 2017 will also be all US
Government cooperation with such groups
and with any groups linked to Hamas and
the Muslim Brotherhood as wer said
yesterday we also have to end
immigration from Muslim countries into
the United States this is a simple
matter of National Security it will of
course be condemned as racism but the
harsh reality is that you cannot tell
peaceful Muslims from jihadis in any
discernible Manner and so it is simply
ridiculous and suicidal to continue to
import whole communities of Muslims from
hot Jihad areas like Somalia and Syria
and Pakistan into the United States and
drop them down into American communities
The Strife has already begun in those
communities and it's going to get worse
we need to reconfigure our International
alliances which are based on old and
outmoded Cold War models I mean for
example we're depending on on Turkey to
do so much to Aid in the fight in
against the Islamic State and yet the
Turkish government has actually refused
when John kery asked them to stop the
oil sales by the Islamic State which is
financing their Jihad the Turks said no
and the Turks are allowing ready passage
of jihadis through turkey into the
Islamic State and from the Islamic State
through turkey into Europe and
ultimately no doubt into the United
States and finally we must begin a
Manhattan Project to find new sources of
oil and viable and new energy sources so
that we end our foreign policy
dependence upon states that Aid and DEET
and support
Jihad and of course this means all of
the options that are available offshore
drilling pipelines from Alaska and
Canada fracking concerted research to
find alternatives to petroleum this
should have been done on September 12th
2001 and every day we don't do it is
another day we lose that we could have
started to turn this thing around and
for the truth to Prevail there's one
more thing above all that we have to
fight against that's a stronger enemy
than the Islamic jihadis and stronger
than Russia and China and that is of
course the entrenched culture that comes
from the left the culture of self-hatred
that denigrates everything and every
Everything American and exalts the most
inveterate America haters as heroic and
Underdog striving valiantly against
brutal behemoths like Israel that
entrenched culture is the foremost
obstacle to our defense against Jihad
Terror and it's a NeverEnding tale of
obfuscation a about a genuine threat and
slander of those who call attention to
it we need to call upon the educational
establishment to reject the revisionism
and self-hatred that dominates textbooks
today and more and more comes out every
day about this and to teach that Western
civilization and culture are seriously
threatened and worth defending Islamic
Jihadi are counting upon and
calculatingly employing the rhetoric of
inclusion and multiculturalism to gain
for themselves entree into highest
levels of influence in the United States
government in the media as well as the
final edit of discussion on these issues
in American textbooks we have to demand
a stop to this relearn our own history
value it and teach it to our own
children teaching them to rever and not
find new ways to deride those built the
political and legal institutions of this
country since I'll never get a chance
actually to deliver an inaugural address
I'll end with an excerpt from the one I
had
prepared we do not seek war with Muslim
nations if war is brought to us however
we will defend our nation our allies our
freedom and our families we will not be
subjugated we will never be subjugated
this is a different kind of war from the
wars we've fought in the past it is an
ideological war and a war fought by
Believers in certain ideas rather than
by soldiers from particular Nations and
so we will therefore fight this new kind
of war in a new kind of way no nation of
the world will be a friend to the United
States if it holds the beliefs that led
to the heinous attack on This Nation on
911 and others after it I invite and
call upon the Muslims of the world to
choose a society based on the principles
of the freedom of speech and the
equality of Rights before the law of
which the United States has been the
foremost exponent and make no mistake we
will defend those principles and we will
prevail thank
you um there are some description before
by Mike Finch of what groups are
comfortable here and where our people
might be comfortable there is there are
a group within the Republican party that
wouldn't be comfortable here that's the
grover norquist Wing which accomplished
some serious infiltration during the
Bush Administration ation and David
really and his organization were the
first to point that out and make that an
issue I would make a serious suggestion
which is you draft what you have put it
in the form of a statement and provide
that to all the potential Republican
candidates for president and let's see
who's serious about this
[Applause]
issue thank you Richard you know that's
actually the idea of my framing it in
this way I'm hoping that these things it
seems to me this is just common sense
matters of policy that should have been
implemented right after 9/11 and I would
hope that some candidates will have the
courage to take them
on yes
sir good morning Mr Cutler thank you so
much sorry uh I just want you
forbearance instead of asking a question
just a fast comment you were talking
about the tar of brothers and you know
yesterday I spoke about immigration what
most people don't know and this is why
I'm so concerned about this
single-minded focus on the Southwest
border that start na of Brothers
apparently committed fraud when they
applied for political Asylum yet their
sister was first arrested about 1 month
ago for threatening it seems to be a
family pattern of blowing up her
ex-boyfriend now this isn't loow hanging
fruit this is fruit in the basket why in
the world were these folks still out and
Among Us when they could have all been
rolled up for having committed apparent
fraud what I want people to understand
is that if we don't go after the
Integrity of the immigration system not
only admitting them but providing
political Asylum and other abilities to
embed themselves we're in deep trouble
absolutely so what I suggest is don't
limit it to the Southwest border folks
think of immigration as a system and
that's where we've got to hammer the
politicians don't let them give you the
cop out of just looking at the border
they need to address the entire system
and thank you for indulging my comment
thank you I
I I couldn't agree more that's
extraordinarily important the refugee
resettlement program which heavily
favors Muslim communities and brings as
I said whole communities and puts them
in the middle of American towns and
cities that is nothing to do with the
Southwest border with the southern
border at all it's it's it's a matter of
people flying in to the country by the
sanction and invitation of the uh
immigration service and the state
department and so on and this has to be
addressed yes
sir
um Kenna brtz uh thank you for your
comments you didn't mention anything
about Iran Iran has promised to kill
everyone in America death to America
death to America do you see any
non-military solution to uh the Iranian
situation a military solution to the
Iranian situation would be very
difficult do you see a non-military
solution a non-military solution no uh I
think that the strategy that the
Israelis are apparently pursuing of uh
strange accidents happening to Iranian
nuclear scientists and strange uh
technical failures at uh Iranian nuclear
plants is uh uh very good and I hope
that it continues on a larger scale uh
militarily it would be very difficult to
go into Iran it's a lot more formidable
than Iraq or Syria or Afghanistan uh and
of course now with the impossible Rules
of Engagement that the military is
saddled with and the weakness of the
military as has been explained here at
this point after 13 years of War uh it
would be uh very difficult to get
involved in Iran at this point but I do
think that there are other ways and
ultimately we'll probably uh need to
bomb some of the nuclear facilities as
well yes
ma'am so much of what's happening with
the jihadis is related to social media
and my question is does anybody have the
authority to require the social media to
shut down and is that a good idea in
your opinion does any uh I didn't quite
hear does anybody have the authority to
request that the social media shut this
down and in your opinion is that a good
idea oh I don't think it's a good idea I
know that they are recruiting in social
media and in Facebook and Twitter you
can see Islamic State supporters and of
course I was just this morning working
on Jihad watch and uh saw the video of
the beheading readily there on YouTube
took it right down but it was up but
another site and
uh I'm not I'm not sure that that uh
this should be stopped because I'm a
strong advocate of the freedom of speech
in general but this is not really a
matter of freedom of speech it is
propaganda from an enemy during wartime
the problem is that I'm afraid that if
you say to Facebook and Twitter that you
need to stop the accounts of extremists
that they'll stop
mine and those of people like us
rather than those of the Islamic State
and other
jihadis if we had a sane society and a
sane uh group of people at the head of
those organizations then it might be
different but not in the present
climate Robert does Islam exist without
Jihad and Sharia Islam does not exist
without Jihad and Sharia there has never
been a form of Islam that did not
include the teaching that Muslims must
fight against non-muslims and impose
Islamic law upon them and Islamic law
denies them basic rights there is no
sect no school of law no understanding
of Islam that has ever been in history
that did not teach that and so the idea
that this is a tiny minority of
extremists who have twisted and hijacked
the teachings of the religion is
absolutely false on the face of
it yes sir
[Music]
as we have a head of the CIA who is a
self- admitted Muslim do we have a
Muslim in the White House well you know
the head of the CIA is not actually a
self- admitted Muslim he is apparently a
Muslim John guondo who is an FBI agent
for many years he says that when he was
in the bureau it was an Open Secret and
it was well known that Brennan had
converted while he served in Saudi
Arabia but Brennan has never actually
publicly addressed this either to
confirm or deny it and there was a story
in I believe the uh New Yorker a lengthy
story about our counterterror apparatus
a few years ago that identified a
highlevel counterterror official as a
convert to Islam and that's probably
Brennan but he has not openly admitted
this in any case is Barack Obama a
Muslim I don't know he doesn't answer my
emails or return my
calls uh but I can tell you that of
course in terms of Islamic law he is a
Muslim because he his father was a
Muslim and his stepfather was a Muslim
he himself says that he was got in
trouble for making faces during quoran
class in one of his autobiographies he
says this and that is in Quran class in
Indonesia you only went to Quran class
if you were a Muslim the Christians
didn't go to Quran class later on of
course he joined Reverend Wright's
church and during the 2008 campaign
somebody called reverend Wright's church
and said I'm a Muslim but I'd like to
join your church is it okay can you have
Muslims be members of your church and
they said oh yes absolutely and so the
thing is ultimately though we do not
know what Barack Obama's personal
beliefs are and I'm not really sure he
has any uh except for certainly Marxism
and uh and and socialism but there's no
doubt that everything about his foreign
policy has been in line with the Muslim
Brotherhood agenda every aspect of it
and you can say well no he killed Bin
Laden and alaki well sure the Muslim
Brotherhood has a different strategy
they do not generally pursue violence
they won the election in Egypt and took
power they didn't bomb everything in
Egypt and take power it was a difference
of strategy however not of goal and
everything about the Muslim
brotherhood's goal to bring Islamic law
to various countries Barack Obama has
aided so whether he's doing that because
he is himself a Muslim or or just
because he thinks that Islamic law is a
good thing for societies and that seems
to be clear I don't think it makes
really a difference in terms of his
policies yes
[Music]
ma'am for the mic oh when Hillary runs
do you think it's a good idea that um
the our side will would
um uh introduce her connections to the
Muslim Brotherhood um um um abedine uh
that whole section and would that be a
beneficial um route to take uh against
her the first way I'll answer that is to
say that if the Republicans bring up
Hillary's connections to the Brotherhood
and haa abedin's connections to the
Brotherhood during the campaign it will
backfire on them and they will be
denounced as racists and bigots and hate
mongers and so on and so that is never
going to happen but what does need to
happen in a larger sense is that there
needs to be a general challenge to the
idea that any talk about this is racism
and bigotry and hatred and this we have
to stop tolerating it on the right and
all too often we do and people in the
Republican establishment they're either
with Grover norquist as has been said
and Grover norquist is tied to the
Brotherhood or they are too afraid
because they don't want this controversy
and they don't want these charges of of
racism and bigotry so they're too afraid
to touch this
issue but that that comes with a high
price as I said before people are being
killed because of our refusal to
confront this issue honestly and so if
we do not take it on then it is only
going to redound to to it's only going
to make things worse in the long run it
has to be confronted sooner or
later yes
sir good morning thank you very much for
that very inform
presentation thank you I come here to
learn a lot more than what I get from
other places but as I listen to your
presentation why isn't this the same as
what happened to our country regarding
communism where it started slowly and
Congress finally had open hearings to
bring it to the Forefront of the
American people why don't we have
something like that now because it seems
to me the only way to get the Americans
on board is to get Congress to have open
hearings now certainly they're going to
going to be those on the left that
disagree and there's going to be those
on the right they're going to be
different but this is no different to me
than communism but for one thing these
are groups that are not attached to
countries communism was so why not have
open hearings in Congress to bring it to
the American people well the answer is
because it actually is a lot like the
Communist threat in the sense that the
left was is was in in terms of the
Communist threat and is in terms of the
Jihad tied in with the Enemy and you
know you say there were Congressional
hearings and of course there were but
then after that came the demonization of
every opposition to Communism as
McCarthyism and that persisted until the
Berlin Wall fell and I remember all the
time I was growing up and until I 27
when it fell knowing that uh Fierce
opponents of Communism were stigmatized
in the American mainstream and demonized
and David harowitz knows that very well
from his own experience but that's the
boldness of leadership that's the
boldness of Michelle Bachman people like
her yeah who we don't have bold leaders
now type of people the of the world who
get this out there and don't fear
demonization and character I couldn't
agree more we need them we do not have
them I hope that such leaders will
emerge but the uh the sophistication of
the propaganda apparatus to demonize and
stigmatize anyone who speaks out about
this threat and to marginalize them in
the mainstream it is much more
sophisticated now than it was even with
the in during the Cold War and so I
think that's one of the reasons why
these leaders have not emerged that it
is just political suicide to take to
take on this problem we had Pamela
Geller and I had a a conference at CPAC
a few years ago that we called Jihad the
political third rail you know the third
rail in the New York subways the one if
you touch it you die and that's how most
of our politicians regard this but I do
believe that's wrong they should not be
playing this game and letting these
people get away with this we need a
Reagan I hope he
emerges we have time for me one more
question how about Sandy Usher up
front I have a l voice um there it is oh
thank you uh Robert I I like the idea
over here of you putting it in a
bulletin point so and putting it on your
website so that I can download it and
pass it around I will and I also want to
tell everybody let's pass it around
we've heard it let's get it out there we
we don't have those bold leaders and I
send loads of Christmas cards every
Christmas I never send one without some
bullet point information there's too
much ignorance going on out there that
stamp costs a lot of money I want to
make it
worthwhile and Robert even you even you
dear Robert use the word mistake this is
no mistake it's design oh yes absolutely
yes uh it's a mistaken application but I
have no doubt that it is uh on purpose
and actually Thomas Patrick uh brought
this up uh a couple days ago in the same
connection I don't know if he's here now
but uh in any case the fact fact is that
during the 2008 campaign Barack Obama
was seen reading the post- American
World by fared Zakaria and he was very
much engrossed in the book he was
carrying it from one airplane to
wherever else he was going with his uh
finger in his place he he he wasn't
going to miss a minute in talking about
in reading this book now I don't know if
you know the book but the post-american
world is about how if we want World
Peace we have to weaken America
militarily politically and economically
and bring it down to the level of all
the other countries and not have any
superpowers in the world and then there
will be peace when Pamela Geller and I
wrote the book The post- American
presidency about Obama in 2010 we were
arguing that that was the strategy he
was pursuing the post-american world
strategy to weaken America in order to
bring about this Chimera of world peace
and I think we've been abundantly proven
correct in the four years since
then thank you very much
much